i have 10 plots of land and we just
spawned 100 players on each plot of land
they have one hour in which everyone
builds the nicest country gets thirty
thousand dollars and joining us today we
have it's fundy as well as tommy yeah my
team is gonna win so much money five
four start
purple purple there's thirty thousand
dollars on the line what we're gonna do
is a city theme with lots of naruto in
it i want you to make some really cool
medieval stuff go do something everyone
is now building their countries and we
are responsible for judging them have
you guys ever judged a country i'm such
a judgmental guy all the time whoa look
at brown team how do you guys already
have a highway it's been like five
minutes
i just want you to know brown team that
i am rooting for you
tommy's team has barely touched the
ground brown team has a highway system
they're already working on their first
buildings tommy's teams are just like
hanging out yellow looks like they've
got a lot going on here these guys don't
have a leader but i know they're just
all running around screaming p team's
doing pretty good oh snap the shot
mrbeast.com is beautiful oh my god look
pig team's making a mountain that's
actually really cool pink team i'm
looking at your plot you guys are
killing it how are you being so
organized
if you keep this up one of you is gonna
be walking away with thirty thousand
dollars all right have fun
wait am i allowed to troll people zap
you can do whatever you want this guy's
trying to build i keep destroying it oh
wait is this bikini bottom yellow's
making bikini bottom this is awesome
this patrick build is insane the other
team has a shot mr b sign we'll put
something like that similar but better
and spongebob who cares about spongebob
hey tommy this is kind of boring tommy
wait does this work
what tommy just banned bundy bubble team
we won't have this all right bad tommy
okay i'm not banned anymore we're fine
we're good wait hold on you guys are
actually killing it with the mountain
this looks really good
we're about 20 minutes in and purple's
got some roads and it's about it pink
doesn't look very organized but they got
a lot going on like the medieval theme
was going well until the among us and
idiot me i think he looks just like you
orange is working on some big skill
projects i'm sure towards the end this
thing is really going to come together
white team over here they're looking
like they have potential they're clearly
trying to go for a futuristic look if
white can actually finish their build i
think it'll look the best black teams
again they're not really doing it for me
i'm going to be honest i can help them
oh yeah oh oh oh oh oh
oh no no stepped up
oh they're mad at me they're punching me
they're all punching me
hello guys
i'm unsubscribing i got a debug stick
does it work uh doesn't seem to be doing
anything
why mr beast my team can't cheat this is
dumb mr beast my team can't cheat this
is dumb
you're mom
guys come to me come to me there's green
wolf and there's red wolf stand up the
green wolf you want me to ban mr b stand
on the red wolf not it's not going to be
my fault if it happens it seems like
more people are on green
he banned me what yes whoa fundy banned
you
i know i keep going back to bikini
bottom but dude i know this is sick
they're doing the sky flowers look how
good this like thing of spongebob is
he's making flying dutchman's ship in
the air oh wow that's cool what's up
yellow team what's up i love the
spongebob design you guys got going on
here honestly i would say you're in
first place at the moment
pull it through guys you guys got this
tom berg i missed a beast oh wait you're
green team now no no i'm just i was
making sure they were doing good you
were sabotaging weren't you no that
would be rude and i'm not rude tommy
honestly man as it stands right now
you're not getting a shout out
i'm trying my best if you want a shout
out figure it out jimmy just told me we
need to figure it out because i want i
want this shout out
you should be useful
if you don't mean this please
oh i will where are you why
just got killed could you imagine being
that bad at minecraft why is my own team
killing me
carl guess what time it is half past
freckle sure it's also 40 minutes in the
competition they only have 20 minutes
left let's give orange team a little bit
of a challenge
okay goodbye
what was that sound fun day
get out of here tommy my team rebelled
against me and killed me can i join
yours why is there a wizard i spawned a
wither in yours but can i join your team
please no it's going good at my team i
get the dub i'm just saying when you see
two withers in your base oh my god tell
me what are you no are you kidding me
dummy
pink team they're like craters oh wait
oh my god their build is getting
destroyed right before my eyes how
there's a hacker i'm watching him
destroy everything
there's about 10 minutes left and pink
got screwed over by a hacker i think we
should help them fix it yeah i don't
ever want to hear you guys say i don't
care about you look at this i'm doing
charity work right now
it's over no more ability no
guys i just want to say i'm super proud
of you all except if you lose then i
will disown every one of you the judges
are me sapnap carl hi hi we're gonna be
raiding these builds on a scale of one
to ten these guys had lots of creativity
it's not horrible but it's not great i'm
gonna give it a seven i'm gonna give it
a seven also zap nap look these
gentlemen in the face know that if you
give them a low score you're ripping 30
grand out of their hands i give them a
five that's a 19. all right over here to
black team i like this build a lot more
and here's why it has the teen titans
building i'm giving it a seven and a
half the logo's great the cookie's cool
but i'd say it's also a seven not like
crazy i think this one's like a little
bit better than the last one so i'll
give it a six all right so now they're
in first place first off in the green
one we have an among guest character on
my diamond sword this is cool i don't
know it felt like that they were trying
to buy you and it worked eight i do like
the big ben build i'm gonna give it a
seven i'm kind of disappointed no one's
trying to buy my vote but this is pretty
good i'll give it a seven as well now
it's time for white the futuristic city
of the future this one is really cool
they have a cool boat they have a light
rail and then they also have a bunch of
flying cars i'm gonna go ahead it's my
new favorite eight and a half i think
it's good i don't think it's that good
i'm gonna hit him with the six
it's my favorite so far i'll give it a
7.5 currently white is in first place yo
wait what are they doing are they
walking in a line over here holy cow
walking in a line how are they doing
this get ready get ready everyone get
ready get ready
they're trying to make up for their poor
design and lack of effort with the line
i mean there's nothing here and tommy's
in the lead oh what is up tommy
we've got me and my gang uh people can
you guys speak or is he enslaving you
watch this watch this you ready you
ready go
tommy can you just control them yeah
yeah stop people stop stop
wow you know what just for that i've
given you an eight out of ten
[Music]
okay you know what i like the
doofenshmirtz building so i'm giving it
an eight bomb as well if i give you guys
a high score you guys could have a shot
at winning and
i'm just not gonna do that you guys get
a like a like a six is all right
i'm sorry guys i have to be a fair judge
fundy you wanna show us around teach us
about your build so over here we got the
giant mountain with houses on top right
whoa look at the mr b statue yeah look
at look at that yo and i got my own
defender on top what up wakka wakka yt
over here we got this thing happening
which is something this is definitely
something but the main thing i want to
show you follow me into the castle you
you can go up front but make sure to go
slow they know what to do
oh my god they just bowed to you jimmy
look what they do
they're bowing thank you jack jack for
the bow oh
oh
[Applause]
the reason why it's not 100 decorated is
because of this we wanted your opinion
about what the room should be my opinion
is it should have just been done let's
start off with sap you know it had a
good idea just there's a lot of
unfinished stuff i give it a seven i
think that this is a great direction but
i'm gonna have to give it a nine that's
okay that's okay that's okay i think
it's good i'm gonna give you guys an
eight as well wait this is in the lead
now
here's what's next boys you know what's
coming up it's time for yellow now
people are gonna think we're biased
because of cartoons and we are and we
definitely are but cartoons aside they
have a very very clear theme they
changed the entire floor they filled up
the map look at how empty that is
compared to this and there's so many
references yeah okay i'm gonna be the
first to say it so you guys don't copy
me it's a tenth oh they have sandy's
dome over here ooh but it's not finished
i'm gonna have to talk a point for the
unfinished dome i think they're an eight
an eight this was amazing i don't know i
think this is a 10 for me as well that's
28 points which means they just won 30
grand holy cow they did it
here's the thing only one of you is
getting 30 grand we have 78 blocks here
because yellow team had 78 players some
people disconnected during the challenge
i'm going to pick this brick block now i
have it i want you each to stand on a
different block and whoever standing on
the block that's in my inventory gets
the 30 thousand dollars
go pick your favorite block
and the winning block
is a brick congratulations super cuber
super cuba you just won thirty thousand
dollars thank you so much mr beast what
do you want to say to the world everyone
watching subscribe and you're very chill
for someone who just won 30 grand
goodbye